the idea came from mr. Boehner of Ohio
who was head of the conservative
opportunities Council and he came to me
two weeks ago when he suggested that it
might be good for the country and good
for the Congress if we had a real clash
of ideas and a real debate on some of
the most important issues facing this
country I thought it was a great idea I
went back to the members of the
Progressive Caucus they thought it was a
great idea we're ready to go what are
you saying about what is going on right
now on the floor of the house are you
basically saying there's not much debate
going on yeah well Jim when I'm I'm very
frustrated i think most members of
Congress are frustrated with how little
the american people really know I as to
what's going on in Congress or in fact
are knowledgeable about the most
important issues facing this country the
corporately owned mass media in my view
does a horrendous job we spend more time
with violence and sensationalism and
five second sound bites rather than
honest debate about the terrible crises
facing this country this country is
undergoing major economic decline our
people are becoming poorer but one of
two nations in the industrialized world
without a national health care system we
lead the world the industrialized world
among poverty for our kids etc etc etc
where is the debate how did this happen
who owns America we're not having that
debate so I think that having some
people from the right and some of us who
are progressives on the left really
clash and talk about the future of
America talk about the problems facing
this country will give the American
people an opportunity to hear serious
debate and I think that that's a real
positive thing tell us specifically when
this will happen the first debate as i
understand it will be wednesday november
third our and it will be on the
single-payer health care system
obviously I and Jim McDermott will be
participating in that debate believe
that the Canadian single-payer system is
the most cost-effective way to provide
comprehensive universal health care all
Americans I presume I think without fear
of contradiction that our conservative
Republican friends will disagree and
there will be then a vigorous debate on
the enormously important issue of
national health care in this country and
the debate will take place within the
format of special orders yeah what we're
going to do and I think it's it's the
best
thing to do is to in a sense do it
informally all that has to happen is a
member requests an hour and then that
member then we'll give it over to a
moderator who will conduct our the
debate in an agreed-upon format with
certain time for each participant you of
course are the only independent in the
US Congress and let me tell you
something the longer I'm here the more
and more proud I am of my state and
myself for that achievement yes I'm the
only independent in the house and you
lined up with John Boehner who some
would describe as fairly conservative
john is a very conservative Republican
that's right another part of the
equation over here the Democratic
leadership has been talking about what
they are saying is oxford style debate
you what's your reaction to that I don't
think it makes a damn bit of difference
whether whatever it is they've been
talking about it and talking about and
that's what goes on here for years
people talk about it it's not that
complicated John proposed a approach
which i think is sensible it's fair you
give proponents a certain amount of time
people who are in opposition a certain
amount of time and you have the debate
then these guys have been talking about
this forever and I think what I'm proud
of is that John and I are moving this
thing along a lot more rapidly and they
were thinking about would you see
yourself part being able to participate
in what they come up with later well I'm
not quite sure that the Democratic
leadership would want me to defend their
point of view my point of view is a bit
more progressive than the Democratic
leadership but I think within the
Progressive Caucus we have a number of
very very bright people who are
concerned about the major issues facing
this country we went around the room and
it'll be people pairing off on on
particular issues I myself feel very
strongly about the need for single-payer
canadian-style system obviously Vermont
borders Canada so that's an issue that I
have a familiarity with jim mcdermott
request as the author of the major
single-payer bill in the house and gym
as a physician very knowledgeable about
the issues I think will be present our
case well and I'm sure the Conservatives
will do their best as well well there's
been a great deal of surprise because
most people wouldn't see Bernie Sanders
and I coming to an agreement on anything
and and so there's been your typical
harassment by some members in a friendly
way but most people have been very
supportive of the idea that there's been
some concern over special orders that go
on
after regular session is over that maybe
they should be limited others want to
argue that that we should keep them but
we want to do is to make special orders
more meaningful and that we think that
bringing the debates to the to the House
floor can help do them the moderator
would be another member of Congress
there would be an agreement between
their group and ours as to who the
moderator would be and who the
timekeeper would be but we have to do it
within the structure of the current
special orders and so that time is
allotted to a member and that member in
effect would have to be the moderator
and yield time to each side and and
organize the debate are we likely to see
a many members sitting in the chairs of
watching the debate I'm not sure that at
first we're going to see a lot of people
on the House floor during these but we
believe if they're successful if they're
done right if we have the right issues
and the right members involved that over
the next few months that these debates
can grow and become more of an event
hopefully on a weekly basis here in
Congress and one last question it's no
secret that the Democratic leadership is
talking about what they're calling
oxford style debates when the floor the
house possibly what is your reaction and
how does this fit into that well we
looked at the possibility of other
debate formats the lincoln-douglas
format is is pretty well structured with
a limited number of people on each side
and we think that within an hour you can
get to the heart of a question with
oxford style debates anybody sitting in
the room is entitled to to involve
themselves in the debate and we think
that that could get out of hand it could
be rather ruckus and and we're not sure
that the question then can be fully
explored and that's the whole idea here
can we fully explore a question in a
specific amount of time and so we
settled on the lincoln-douglas style and
it's going to be incumbent upon us to
structure questions that are narrow
enough yet broad enough to be discussed
in an hour period of time Congressman
John Boehner thank you thank you